did you know do you know about the
extended state dmt experiments they're
doing
uh that's the that's the iv drip yep and
i told joe on that show four years ago
about six months before it came out they
broke the news because i pushed him to
do it that it's not a corporate party
though it's a university university well
i mean i knew because my mom knew people
that were doing it uh in the 70s and 80s
with the cia in in san francisco at this
big uh
university group you know you know i
guess but i said that on joe's show
before it came out yeah and i was a kid
my because my parents were involved they
had friends that were research
scientists and they were talking about
one time i was asleep in the back of the
volkswagen when my mom with her friend
was driving up to uh
to uh arkansas you know travel around
and see some cool places and i'm sitting
in the back of the car listening to this
talking about how they're having groups
of people take this having the same
experience going into these dimensions
talking to these aliens they believe
they're aliens but that they're they're
sneaky they lie they're basically demons
they're like clockwork elves so i i'm
sitting in the back of the car hearing
my mom drive along with somebody who's
you know i mean they're talking to a
friend i'm six seven eight nine years
old repeatedly and they i mean so these
are research scientists in san francisco
in a university study you know at the
psychedelic research institute or
whatever it's called i'm going back from
memory and then it's actually people on
different hallucinogenic drips long term
going in like mapping everything and
then coming out of it writing it all
down what they saw then going back
trying to communicate the things always
say we want you to kill children
why
like
it starts off with this amazing
fantastic journey of like uh you know
through the through the back in the
world
you go through the back of the imagine
this why do you think joseph mingler did
it why do you think okay hold on let me
let me let me what do you think these
people are into there's a story about
several children
doesn't want gold he wants children's
blood
let me tell you a story a bunch of
children are playing hide and seek in
their in their family home as their
parents are out about working
when young one of the young children
goes to open the wardrobe to go and hide
but behind in the back of the wardrobe
there is no wall narnia and they stumble
hold on they stumble into this amazing
winter wonderland where a giant lion
rise up and says bring me the blood of
children
see that's where you lose me well they
want the blood of the lion in that in
that story but i know i know i know it's
like you start off with this fantastic
journey it's like it's like they want to
meet the interdimensional so you ask for
the proof every culture builds pyramids
and starts cutting children's hearts out
everyone almost every culture the druids
the africa has done it the point is in
europe they did it all over the druids
whether it was scotland ireland which
england today germany uh the visigoths
with what's what's switzerland today
there's huge mounds of pyramids they're
in china everywhere they did it
and they dig into them and it's children
with their hearts cut out in asia too
yeah yeah they but they fixed they
stopped doing that as much about 5000
years ago they did it first but the
whole point is they always take a lucid
agent and then they put
a string with obsidian through their
tongue and then just go ah and then cut
their genitals off well that's that's
the highest level for the aztec priests
and others and finally then they just
commit suicide
to the god while they're on drugs so
you know what's really difficult is when
you're like fauci's name means sickle
and then we look it up and it's true but
then you say that
yeah most cultures finally declined that
priesthood
the priest class finally kill themselves
look up the aztecs drawing
ropes with
with glass through their genitals
i'm not gonna look that up and that's
volcanic glass in case anyone's
wondering i recommend
you know madrid
museum of natural history where they
have a whole area of it and they have
carvings for their 500 years old brought
back from
from there of jumbo jets with the
windows on it and the two engines
i've got this feeling that that the
energy source doesn't want us to do
anything it's just there and people it's
passing through this this imperfect
filter of the human body where we need
to eat we need to destroy to consume to
survive so it's got this taint and a lot
of really powerful people are using it's
like their own warped perception of what
they think it's
is it yes humans could be projecting
because it only hits our lower brain
that what it wants us to do is eat
children so so going back to stargate
right there's an episode where it's
richard dean anderson by the way great
actor he he accidentally gets hooked
into very quickly an ancient knowledge
repository which begins downloading all
of the ancient information to his brain
but his brain is primitive and can't
handle it so it starts erasing his
cognitive functions and then he slowly
can't talk and he's so you know just
kind of like what you guys were saying
you get this this energy from this
all-powerful or interdimensional higher
being your brains can't handle that and
it makes you chop your genitals off okay
and that's how the head you know it also
doesn't just say kill kids it says it
tells men chop your genitals off that's
the transmission you get and then they
do a final ritual where they they don't
just draw strings of their tongue or cut
their ears off then they start they like
gouge their eyeballs out
and then slit their throat but so you're
looking back at this the highest level
ritual for the high priests to finally
kill themselves that's why you had some
roman emperors that killed themselves
and stuff but they'd already burned down
the city you know i would get into these
deep meditative trances in like 2012 13
and i was hearing is i thought it was
god like and i would hear like die die
and i was like what is this voice what
it's like this human it's like it's
vibrating in our atmosphere and it's
like the collective consciousness is
being filtered into words and they're
telling us kill ourselves that but
that's why schwab goes you will soon be
very angry what we have done is for the
earth soon they will be angry and they
go we're all just going to rise up and
kill each other they also tell us
schwab is schwab is definitely creepy
and he's probably a bond villain um i've
i've meditated a
fairly decent amount and i have never
heard a voice in my head
it only happened between 2011 and 2012.
it was a very specific period of history
where everything was changing 2011 and
it must have been a collective like that
is selfie the least mindful thing that i
could almost i wasn't yeah experiencing
what i'm trying to be mindful it was
remember the kingsman though that came
out where the billionaire is gonna send
a signal to their phones to make you
kill yourself the movie yeah and that's
basically what the great reset is to get
us to hate each other i don't think i
don't think that's it i pull up clash
schwab says we're going to have a very
angry time everyone's going to be very
angry but we will fix it soon with
greater reset which is they're doing it
all right overthrow cause a revolution
that sounds very russian
i don't have trouble in germany but he's
kind of he's german
belgian he has a mixed action he's
creepy i wonder but hold on
i wonder if you take it yeah the great
reason never he does he's a cut and once
the cut happens you'll never go back to
normal your face looked like him for a
second from over here i i wonder if you
should know so here's
let's let's let's let's try and uh
everyone uh we'll do it looks like
nosferatu
deep breath pull up nosferatu deep
breaths all right deep breath all right
phil keep breathing
so here's here i'll tell you what i've
said about you in the past
i thought i was going to be calm you
said you were going to become man watch
this
okay there we go oh yeah yeah you you
find a story and sometimes you'll take
this this this point of truth and
stretch it too much
so like the great reset stuff now there
are temples worldwide where everybody
murders children and women and finally
cuts their genitals off i where's the
proof of that i mean it's everywhere in
every anthropological and archaeological
no i understand in ancient traditions
and stuff like that and the globalists
are obsessed with it now i mean i mean
this whole the national satan group came
out and said killing babies is our
sacrament
hold on they're talking about abortion
yeah to use to claim first amendment
religious rights to get around it like
hope he's taking peyote but no they
really mean
that's what i'm saying about you taking
a morsel of truth and stretching it
there's a big difference between a
clearly political group using satan
because it offends christians and then
trying to use that decline and it's also
a religious symbol i've seen their movie
hell satan they
by the end it's really taken but these
these people the satan group
specifically say they don't believe in
satan they don't believe in religion
they don't believe in any supernatural
entities
and they're doing this
so did anton levay believe me they
believe it all the church of satan is
definitely just like edge lords that's
really what they are they're just like
okay it's not the church of satan it's
it's it's the other group that's really
political the democrats
it's a satanic temple yeah
they're the ones on twitter right the
ones that we're just talking about the
uh no i have a
my lawyer mark randazzo i think
represents them the point is that's okay
they get their first amendment i get
mine but believe me
believe me i've taken one look at those
people and seen their movie and then
they're like yeah we just do this we
think it's cool it's all destructive
they're all very weak they're seeking
after power of this world but so i i
look at this group
and you look at their core principles
and i how much you want to bet i'll read
their principles so you'd agree with
them no i know it's human empowerment
and all this other stuff and autonomy
individual rights but you support the
democratic party which ain't happening
right exactly
the one the one freedom is oh your body
but we want you to have force
inoculations and we don't believe alex
jones should have free speech
ask him
so i i look at the uh
they called my lawyer up and told him we
don't want to we don't want you to
represent alex jones or we're going to
kick you fire they said fine
temple did yeah i think that was the
group yeah
the satanic temple rep people called
your lawyer or what yeah my lawyer
represents the biggest satan group in
america i mean one of my lawyers i got a
lot of lawyers he's one of the top first
amendment lawyers so you're going to
support people you got to support me you
know right and
and so the issue is
it's like people representing larry
flynn i don't like a lot of larry flint
did but he published two of my articles
that i wrote about 911 an inside job
uh and you know in hustlers so you know
i don't i don't agree with the whole sex
trade and all that kind of stuff but
i'll get my stuff published where i can
just like people should come on here
it's a venue to talk to millions of
people what the hell is it oh who's
there who's it going to be on a bunch of
self-righteous sanctimonious idiots the
left today are actually the the
oppressors of information they're
actually the people they're orthodoxy
covering up the horrible evil
megacorporations they run they're
totally cold-blooded and again run slave
camps all over the world we can name all
their names so they want a faction
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you